الحديث عن السيارات الوسيله التي شهدت
معنا العام الماضي كل التحديات الاقتصاديه
والبيئيه فبعد ان كانت سيارات التقليديه
التي تعمل بواسطه محركات الاحتراق الداخلي
اكبر تحدي استهلاكي جاءت لاول مره منذ 18
شهرا في اواخر عام 2022 اكثر اقتصادا من
نادراتها الكهربائيه وذلك مع ارتفاع اسعار
الكهرباء واستقرار اسعار النفط العالميه
بحث اجرته شركه الاستشارات اندرس
وركزت على تتبع التكلفه الاساسيه للطاقه
بالنسبه للسيارات التي تعمل بالبنزين
وديزل والكهرباء مع الاخ في الاعتبار
ضرائب ورسوم الطرق وتكلفه الوصول الى
محطات الوقود ومحطات الشحن للسيارات
الكهربائيه في حاله القياده طبعا لمسافه
160 كم في الساعه وجدت النتائج النتائج
السيارات التي تعمل بالوقود دفع لتزويد
سيارته بالطاقه بنحو 31 سنتر اقل من سائق
السياره الكهربائيه عندما يشحن سيارته في
المنزل
والله ما يزيد على 3 دولارات اقل من ما
يدفعه سائقون سيارات الكهربائيه عند شحن
سياراتهم في محطه الوقود
المزيد معنا
صانعه السيارات الكهربائيه يتسابقون
لتصميم مركبات اقل تكلفه للجمهور لكن
مشكله العرض والطلب تتسبب في زياده
الاسعار بدلا من انخفاضها بالاضافه الى
ارتفاع اسعار بطاريات اليوتيوب بنسبه 500%
خلال 2022 في نوفمبر الماضي بلغ متوسطه
تكلفه السيارات الكهربائيه الجديده
65,000$ بينما بلغ متوسط تكلفه السيارات
التي تعمل بالوقود
48.681$ قله محطات الشحن هي احدى اكبر
العوائق التي تحول دون الاعتماد الكلي
للمركبات الكهربائيه لكن العالم يسعى
للحلول وفقد امريكا مؤخرا على خطط لبناء
محطات في جميع ولاياتها خلال الخمس سنوات
المقبله بتكلفه تقدر بخمسه مليارات عام
22 اا افضل عام من حيث مبيعات السيارات
الكهربائيه الجديده رغم ذلك مثلت
16.6% فقط من حصه السوق بينما بلغت حصه
السيارات التي تعمل بالوقود اثنتين
واربعين فاصل ثلاثه بالمئه رغم ان تسلا هي
رائده السيارات الكهربائيه الا ان ست من
اعلى 10 سيارات كهربائيه مبيعا حول العالم
تعود لشركات صينيه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
بيروت ينضم لان العالم الرياضي جورج سويدي
جورج يسعد صباحك اهلا بك هل فعلا سيارات
التقليديه اقل تكلفه من نظراتها
الكهربائيه في التشغيل
صباح الخير سهام سهام ونادين اكيد يعني
هذا الموضوع هيك خاصه دائما هناك مقارنه
بين مصروف السياره العاديه ومصروف السياره
الكهربائيه لكن هذا بيختلف طبعا على كل
منطقه يعني اذا اخذنا الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه حسب كل الوليه ايضا سعر صحيفه
البنزين همم يختلف يعني ممكن يوصل لجعله
يعني جعله حواله ثلاثه
في بعض همم الولايات همم
وهنا بتختلف المقارنه ايه يعني همم اذا
بدنا ناخذ سياره عاديه من اربع اسطوانات
يعني ايه اربع سيلاند قارنها بالسياره من
الموضه الثري بالسيارات الكهربائيه يعني
كمان بنفس الحجم تقريبا همم افضل انه تكون
السياره كهربائيه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه بما انه مثل ما ذكرنا ثلاثه
فاصله سبعه ثمانيه اذا عملناها على 100
مايل همم
في السياره الكهرباء اي محولها يعني اذا
بدنا نشرس سياره كهربائيه حوالي اربع
دولار بينما من ناحيه ثانيه بتكلف حوالي
11$ تقريبا سوء السياره عاديه همم على
فتره ماء
سخريه القدر وللمفارقه انه اول ما بلشوا
يصنعوا سيارات كهربائيه كانت السلينج
بوينت تبعتهم احنا ارخص واقل تاكله هلا عم
تطلع دراسات يعني عم تنفي كل الموضوع كل
النقطه والحجه القويه اللي كانت لمصنعيه
سيارات كهربائيه اليوم اذا اخذنا هذه
الدراسه على عالمنا العربي نحن كيف ستنعكس
علينا هذه المسائل هل فعلا السيارات
الكهربائيه اكثر تكلفه اليوم من التقليديه
التي بحوزه كثير منا او ان كان الكل
اذا بدنا نحكي عن المنطقه العربيه طبعا
يعني كمان اسعار صحيحه البنزين هو ارخص
ايضا من بعض المناطق خاصه باوروبا تكلفه
البنزين باوروبا زادت بشكل كبير بسبب طبعا
الحرب على على اوكرانيا همم بس اذا بدنا
نحكي بشكل عام ناحيه الصيانه يعني بنرجع
نقول بس يكون معانا السياره كهربائيه نحنا
بحاجه بس مثل ما ذكرته التقرير بطاريه
الليثيوم ذات سعرها بسبب يعني هناك كان في
مايكرو شيبس ماكينه موجوده في السوق بسبب
اكيد فايروس
عندنا فقط
وحتى منصور
بالسياره الكهربائيه مستر نغير فرامل على
ال 40 و 50,000 كيلو متر بينهم بالسياره
العاديه عم بنغير
عن غير المكابح كل كل 10 او 15 او 20 الى
تشغيل والصيانه يعني السيارات الكهربائيه
السالزموجود شحنت السلزم موجود محطات شحن
هل هذا متوفر في منطقتنا العربيه
من همم فتره صغيره يعني من ايام قليله
حلبه الدرعيه يعني انت عم تستضيف جوله من
بطوله العالم وهي بطوله العالم للسيارات
اللي بتعمل على المحركات الكهربائيه
وسيارات سريعه جدا اليوم العالم العربي
رايح نحو السيارات الكهربائيه طبعا مثل
كمان بي اوروبا
كانوا 35 راح تختفي السيارات اللي بتعمل
همم المحركات العاديه بتعمل على حرق
الوقود رايحين كله على الكهرباء بس بيبقى
مثل ما ذكرته يعني مراكز الشحن لازم تكون
بتزيد تشارجر ذكرنا مهمه من ناحيه تشريج
السياره او شحن السياره
دائما السياره بتكلف اكثر من السياره اللي
بتعمل على ال على المحرك العادي حولها 16
17 دولار قبل تشرجي السياره على ال على
فاست تشارجر بس هذا منه منيح ايضا لعمر
البطاريه بعدما السياره بدها تاخذ من
ثمانيه الى 10 12 ساعه
وخصوصا في الدول اللي مش متطوره
مزيد من الابحاث والتدقيق اليوم هل
بالمزيد من الابحاث لا تتعلق بالسيارات
الكهربائيه ممكن ان تحل هذه المشكله يا
جورج
يعني هذا هو مزاجكم المطلوب بصراحه انه
تنحل هذه المشكله يكون في مراكش شحن اكثر
ويكون ايضا وسيله الشحن سهله خاصه
بالمنازل يعني
اللي ساكن اليوم بنايه مثلا غير اللي ساكن
ببيت ارضي وعنده الباركينج تبعه وهو يقدر
يشارش سيارته ساعه اللي بده ممكن هي
بتختلف الامور مثل كمان اذا بنرجع على
الطاقه الشمسيه مش كل الناس قادره تركب
طاقه شمسيه خاصه
اه على كل حال جورج بس كمان حابين هيك
نسالك سؤال عنا فضول انت وين بالضبط في
لبنان لانه اعجبوا الناس في الجاليري في
الفيو من وراءك
بمنطقه همم طبرجا بشمال بيروت مثل ما شفته
يعني الطقس اليوم عاصف فيه في امطار انا
صار لي حولها يومين ثلاثه الامطار ومستمره
كالعاده جميل جدا لكن وصلنا للسقعه مضبوط
حاليا نطلع نشوفه يعني هذا منظر خليج جوني
ساعه زميل
مذيع طقس شكرا جزيلا ههه
شكرا جزيلا لاعلامي رياضي جورج وسوف سويتي